voilà c'est un peu de la 8e des fois il
ya des personnes qui te regarde voyez
avec un avec de la pitié qui te parle et
qui tu dises ça va
je suis désolé et enfin sais je sais que
ce sens et revient d'une bonne attention
et enfin en soit ça me dérange pas et
d'effacer un peu perturbant et si
justement pour ça que moi je fais ça
c'est que pour que les gens ils se
disent pas directement ok c'est 100% sûr
que c'est un cancer qui se disent ok
c'est soit un cancer soit une alopécie
ou une pelade quelque chose d'autre on
pose également la question quand j'étais
petit puis à un moment où j'ai demandé à
mes parents genre et vous êtes sûr que
j'ai pas un cancer parce qu'on n'arrête
pas de me le dire vous êtes sûr que je
ne sais pas ça vous êtes sûr que c'est
une alopécie com ou des temps j'allume
brut bienvenue chez moi c'est d'agir je
fais des petites vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui il faut en parler
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sur tik tok notamment je
parle de mon d'alopécie c'est une
maladie qui fait perdre les poils du
corps comme j'ai dit qui donc a voilà
c'est moi c'est vraiment tout en fait
même les poils des gens et ou vince est
annulé moi j'ai eu la lopé si quand
j'avais deux ans donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose avec laquelle je vis
depuis très longtemps je trouve que
c'est une chance j'ai pu m'adapter toute
ma vie avec et c'est pour ça que je le
vis bien aujourd'hui mais il ya des gens
qui on l e et si maintenant en fait plus
tard dans leur vie et qui sont pas prêts
et ça me prend un peu de court et donc
moi j'essaie en en fait par mes vidéos
de leur donner un peu plus confiance en
eux quoi
il fallait
alors enfant c'est vrai que par exemple
je pars à la rentrée je rentrais dans la
classe mais tous les regards se mettait
sur moi parce que c'est vrai que bien
visuellement la levée si ça se voit quoi
surtout bien quand tu es petit est belle
les enfants ils sont un peu cruel entre
eux que j'avais beaucoup de moqueries et
donc je pense que c'est bien de
faire connaître un petit peu plus cette
maladie et je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être pas mal parce que c'est un
truc qui est suivi par notamment les
jeunes il
dit que j'ai une série de vidéos où je
vais sur ces qui s'appelle omegle c'est
un peu comme chatroulette on en fait on
est connecté avec une webcam avec des
inconnus et donc moi je récupère les
réactions donc les réactions mais toutes
les réactions c'est à dire qu'elle est
bonne même si les mauvaises c'est à des
mauvaises et donc c'est super
intéressant de voir la méchanceté et la
bienveillance un peu au même endroit et
ça représente un petit peu ce que ce que
moi j'ai pu vivre
merci beaucoup cette agence
merci beaucoup
tu as une alopécie oui oh
inversée avec la première m'a souvent
dit tu sais que tu vas avoir des
remarques tu sais qu'on va
potentiellement insulté alors ne va pas
à la rencontre des gens et moi je trouve
que c'est pas ça la solution tu vois
c'est vraiment pas ça la solution parce
que le but ce n'est pas se cacher
justement le but c'est de se montrer de
montrer qu'on a confiance en nous toutes
les personnes qui ont le vent dans mon
cas tu as quelque chose de visuel et qui
vont se faire remarquer et bien faites
vous remarquer sorte et montrez-vous et
assumez vous moi ce que j'en dis
je suis serein sur tik tok et two way
mais lorsqu'on prend pas les gens les
gens qui disent ouais tu vois jean la
meuf américaine lah qui t'avait dit
ouais enfin l'ag vous faire voir la
douche je sais pas quoi
mais moi ça me choque d'être métis
c'est bien que ça te choque tueur il
faut que ça choque les gens parce que
c'est des choses qui enfin le poids des
mots il est super important
incident chimique g8 faire qu'en fait ça
mais
aujourd'hui les gens dans l'énorme
majorité c'est de la bienveillance et de
la gentillesse et c'est vraiment trop
cool voilà évidemment il y aura toujours
ceux 1% de personnes sont mal
intentionnées méchante et vraiment c'est
vraiment un pur sang pas un beau chapeau
merci est-ce que tard et une alopécie
aussi oui c'est des plats jean que nous
on a dû bien même on remarque les gens
qui te regardent bizarre les gens qui
pensent que tout un cancer que bien une
forme l'achète vous avez loupé si c'est
pas grave montrer la queue et peu
importe votre genre parce que je sais
que ça peut être plus difficile si vous
êtes genre et au féminin par exemple peu
importe c'est pas grave le moi ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est de voir plein
de gens dans la rue qui ont une alopécie
c'est ça c'est très trop cool ça ça
dépasse l'alopécie c'est tout ce qui est
différent et c'est super important donc
si vous avez vous êtes s'il ya quelqu'un
qui regarde cette vidéo est qui qui qui
ce qui à ce choix de
soi cacher sa différence ou la montre et
montre là